[Música]
esta imagen le dio la vuelta a las redes
sociales en dubai un rabino toca
enchufar este acuerdo por el nuevo año
judío un vídeo inimaginable antes de la
firma de los acuerdos entre los emiratos
árabes unidos e israel' el pasado 15 de
septiembre en pleno corazón del golfo
pérsico la comunidad judía ahora sale de
la sombra las salas de oración se han
multiplicado por seguridad las
direcciones todavía son secretas y los
lugares están protegidos todas las
mañanas unos 20 fieles se reúnen
alrededor de este rabino un judío
ortodoxo estadounidense que llegó aquí
hace seis años
a nuestra comunidad judía aquí en los
emiratos está compuesta por judíos
provenientes del mundo entero judíos
franceses europeos australianos
estadounidenses neozelandeses es una
verdadera mezcla
los que tienen un pasaporte israelí no
podían entrar al territorio una
prohibición que ya ha celebrado a los
judíos europeos que están instalados en
dubai esto les permite practicar su fe
sin tener que esconderse
estos acuerdos lo cambiaron todo hay
muchas personas es mucho más abierto y
tenemos menos miedo de mostrarnos
ahora escuchamos que las personas en las
calles nos saludan salón como están
mohamed vencer el nuevo hombre fuerte
del país cuyo retrato adorna el lugar de
culto quiso normalizar la relación con
israel
el príncipe también inició una obra
gigantesca en la capital un complejo con
mezquita iglesia y sinagoga la
tolerancia religiosa un argumento del
soft pauer para seducir a occidente y
reactivar la economía
antes los emiratos habían convertido la
causa palestina en un eje de política
extranjera pero aquí los cambios de
opinión diplomáticos no se discuten en
esta monarquía absoluta
los disidentes corren el riesgo de ser
encarcelados este emiratí grabó un vídeo
en honor a los acuerdos titulados yo
quiero ir a tel aviv
[Música]
pero
con mis amigos se volvió una broma nos
preguntamos cuándo vas a ir a tel aviv y
nos reímos en los emiratos árabes
unidos- siempre nos acomodamos a las
decisiones de nuestro gobierno aquí
hicimos un paso en dirección a la paz es
en beneficio de la región en beneficio
de los emiratíes y de otros pueblos y
eso nos hará a todos más fuertes
con la llegada de los primeros turistas
israelíes el sector se adapta el hotel
armani al pie de la torre más alta del
mundo abrió un restaurante coche
todos los días un representante de la
comunidad judía verifica que las normas
religiosas sean respetadas es él quien
debe prender el fuego en las estufas o
asegurarse de que no haya rastros de
sangre en los huevos el kosher se
convirtió en una etiqueta muy buscada en
dubai hace dos años el y lanzó un
servicio de entregas a domicilio para
una clientela judía desde hace poco la
restaurantera recibe muchos pedidos de
hoteles de lujo y acaba de contratar a
siete personas
y vamos a hacer pan rallado lo utilizo
en los platos que cocino sobre todo para
los schnitzer en este momento tenemos
mucho trabajo también hay muchas
personas recién llegadas que quieren
estar presentes en este mercado todo el
mundo quiere hacer parte y todos los
turistas judíos quieren visitar guay
tan solo para las fiestas de fin de año
se esperan 100 mil israelíes en dubai y
los emiratos esperan que la
normalización reactiva de otros sectores
inmobiliarios salud seguridad le
apuestan a intercambios que van hasta 4
mil millones de dólares por año en la
bolsa de diamantes de uruguay este belga
de confesión judía ahora puede comerciar
directamente con tel aviv
la otra gran plaza de diamantes del
medio oriente pero no sólo eso creó una
empresa de consultoría para los
inversionistas israelíes que están poco
familiarizados con los códigos del mundo
de los negocios en el golfo
y esta es mi página de linkedin aquí
pueden ver la bandera israelí la bandera
emiratí los israelíes son muy directos
quieren tener resultados y transiciones
rápidas resulta de acción de gap y usan
o se interesan mucho por la persona que
está detrás de la empresa mientras que
los emiratíes les gusta tomarse su
tiempo y sentarse con una taza de té les
gusta mucho saber con quién están
tratando y con quién están haciendo la
transacción
entusiasmado por este nuevo mercado su
socio incluso empezó a aprender hebreo
para este hombre de negocios que viene
de una gran familia emiratí el acuerdo
de paz firmado con israel no constituye
una traición a los palestinos todo lo
contrario primero que todo este acuerdo
permitió detener los planes de anexión y
eso es algo bueno para la causa
palestina porque aquí vimos llegar a
muchos árabes israelíes que son
palestinos y que vinieron aquí para
explorar para hacer negocios entonces
ellos también se han beneficiado
la autoridad palestina denunció estos
acuerdos porque los israelíes precisaron
que el proyecto de anexión sólo se había
pospuesto el hecho es que en el medio
oriente esta fuerte tendencia de
acercamiento entre antiguos enemigos
jurados no parece cerca de acabarse los
emiratos de israel ya prometieron
intercambiar embajadores y bahrein y
sudán también normalizaron sus
relaciones con el estado hebreo